Georgie was saying earlier that a
writer's career trajectory can be an odd
one sometimes and it can take a long
time to reach that one perfect shining
moment that you that you seek for what's
the run-up to that like I think it's
different for every writer I mean the
one thing that's common for fiction
writers and I know and it crowd this
size they're probably a good number of
you who are aspiring writers or people
who who do write and think about writing
someday it's it's not a career for
anyone who needs or values security it's
a career for gamblers because you know
your type you write a book here you're
throwing a dice again and you don't know
whether it's gonna crash and burn or
whether it's gonna be a big success
most folks of course or somewhere in
between it's a career of ups and downs
and I've been very fortunate I've
experienced far more ups than I have
downs but I have had a few downs and you
know dark times where I thought my
career was over and I wasn't sure I was
ever gonna sell another book what's
important to me looking back on those is
that even at the times where I was
afraid I wasn't ever going to sell
another book I never doubted that I
would write another book and that's the
real thing that I think distinguishes a
real writer from from the false ones
that even if you can't sell the books
you're gonna write them anyway because
you got these stories inside you that
you want to tell you have these stories
inside you that that it got to get out
and you got to get it down on paper and
you know hopefully you do hopefully you
persist but it's a tough gig bumpy road
and the obstinacy that writers must have
do you think writers have to be a
certain sort of character you have to be
quite obdurate and quite bloody minded I
think in your in your own skin it's a
quite determined
just keep doing it yes and and you know
you have to you have to be ready to take
a certain amount of criticism and
rejection you are gonna get the
rejection slips you're gonna work for
projects that you love and people aren't
gonna understand what you're doing and
you know and and boy for most writers
you can work for a year or two years on
a book and even if you sell it and get
it published then it's like you you
threw it down a well hopefully you scan
oh here's one one review in a newspaper
from Des Moines Iowa and that's the only
notice that you get for that you if
you're lucky enough to be sent out for
your publisher on book tours you find
yourself sitting in a mall for three or
four hours and no one is coming and
that's funny somewhat you you got a big
stack of books in front of you and and
and you see some someone coming up to
you Oh finally I have a customer yes
that's the kind of experience you hope
you have so it's it's not all you know
book launches with champagne and
interviews by the New York Times or the
London Times as the case may be but it
is a casino when sometimes someone like
me gets lucky and you do get the other
the end of the end of it which has its
own challenges but its own rewards as to
the main thing is the stories though
it's is exactly as Robin said all of the
other stuff is it's fun but or not fun
as the case may be but ultimately you
want to get back to that room and you
want to get back to your to your people
to fits in the fool in your case or to
in my case the Tyrian and are you
so and so forth or stolen absolutely the
best feeling is the feeling that you get
when you when you're really reading a
really cool book and you have to put it
down because it's time to do something
else cook dinner or do homework or
whatever in that feeling I'm going to go
back to that and I'm going to jump back
into that story and when that happens
and you realize that's the story I was
writing that it is is that moment and
when it shifts gears and you say I hope
somebody else is going to feel about
this like I am because I can't wait to
get back and and finish what's going to
happen that was a watershed moment for
Evan oh yes
it's a curious thing this I know exactly
where you're feeling and there are books
I love it when I find a book like that
the book that at the end of the day I
can't wait to read a few more chapters
before I go to sleep and sometimes it
grabs me and then I I don't go to sleep
I stay up all night reading it that's
that's great but it sometimes I wonder
what the quality is what is that
readability I suppose does the job of
editors like gain - to find that because
sometimes I find myself reading a book
critically and sit and saying this isn't
right no no I could do better than this
this is I'm not convinced later but I'm
still reading the chapters because the
book has B book even though I'm
criticizing in my brain really and just
to reverse other books I read sometimes
very highly praised books oh this is
beautiful prose oh this is he's really
he's really got a gift here this is this
is a terrific and I put it down I never
pick it up again even though I have this
great intellectual admiration somehow
the hooks not being set and and I don't
know quite what the distinction is I
don't know if anybody knows if we knew
we would all be doing it with every book
right we would bottle it and sell it but
it's that's why it's in art and not a
not a choice every book every when
you're reading money scripts
and you know and even those don't always
work even if you like it not everybody
else is gonna like it so it's very
intangible I don't know what it is but I
know exactly what you mean about a very
highly praised book and you can you can
really think it's a remarkably well
written but it just hasn't got you and I
now put those away I haven't got time to
waste on things that I'm not going to
enjoy it's it's very magical process
reading I think it's the most personal
thing you can ever do because it's just
you and that story and nobody else can
interfere with it while you're sharing
that book and that's an amazing thing
but also writing is a very magical
process as well and that's also an
intangible extraordinary process and
remember over the weekend you you
described it so beautifully Megan you
said it was like chasing butterflies and
trying not to crush them it's somehow
trying to capture that moment of
inspiration and get it down on paper can
you can you talk a bit more about that
there was a lovely book out and I think
I'm going to mess up the title but it
was a was a fairy book and it was about
this lovely Victorian lady that was
catching fairies in the book that was it
wasn't the crushed fairy book it was it
had a title similar to that and really
for me writing us like that I get an
idea I think I can see it it's
absolutely beautiful and I start writing
it and I get it trapped on the page and
it looks like it's it's not what I
thought I was going to write and then
the rewrite is it's it's rearranging the
little body to make it look nice but
it's taking off the paragraphs that
didn't work and with coming back to it
and saying I really I didn't describe
anything I just said they they walked
into the room and I and the right I'm
not in the room with them because I
haven't bothered to slow down and
describe it so for me it's it's um I
enjoy rewriting much more than I do
doing first drafts doing first drafts
it's like it's like it's really hard and
then rewriting you've at least got
something to work with and you can
always make it better but we hope but
but first drafts are very hard for me
George how are you I agree what what
what everything Robert said about how
hard it is you know one of the one of
the key bits of writing advice that I
got from a book was when I was quite
young before I'd made any sales when I
was ready for families and all that was
up Robert a Heinlein's for rules of
writing which was you know you must
write was number one there's a lot of
people talk I'm gonna write someday but
they never never actually get around to
writing anything so that one I was
already writing so that one didn't make
much sense to me oh I could see the
sense of it but the second one he was
finished what'd you write that was very
important to me at an early age because
I was I was constantly not finishing
what I like I was buried in fragments
for precisely the reasons that Robin
talked about I would have this story
idea and they will exist in my head in
this platonic perfection and I would sit
down to try to capture it and I'd be
writing writing on it and wrestling it
and writing with these words and then I
would look at it and it was not that the
beautiful dream city that I had imagined
it was this kind of slum of words and
and no I didn't get it right it was
horrible and I'd get like halfway
through it and then I'd have another
idea and that would exist in platonic
perfection and we'd seen so much more
attractive than this mess that I had
half written on paper so I put the mess
aside and I start a new story and
exactly the same thing that would happen
would happen it was really the Heinlein
thing that said you must finish what you
write and I made myself start actually
finishing these stories no matter how
much I hated loathe and despise them and
you know by the end I usually like them
a little better
and they still weren't the incredible
stories that I saw in my head but uh you
know they were good enough that at least
for fanzines and fans seem to like them
and that encouraged me and I did more
and you know then after they have
Scandinavian story got rejected I said
well maybe I'll I'll send some out and
one thing led to another
but it's hard it's still it's still hard
I mean if there was just telepathy you
know it's part of me that loves words I
mean I feel great pleasure when I come
up with a great line of dialogue or even
a way of describing a sunset or a castle
a metaphor something that that were the
words ring what or decimo tree to them
that's terrific but sometimes it seems
like the words are you know you're
trying to drive a nail with your shoe
and it's it's boy you wish you had a
hammer and the hammer is a word that you
don't have or or some way to make the
reader see that's the way you see it
that it it can be very very frustrating
Thomas Mann said a writer is someone for
whom writing is more difficult than it
is for other people